Alright guys, so in this video I will go over the 4 hour auto block trading strategy in detail. I have uploaded a couple of videos on this topic on YouTube but in this video I will explain it in detail. So basically it is an auto flow trading strategy but it is a bit unique to the normal traditional auto flow trading strategy.
So this is how we look at it.
So number one thing is, look at the autoflow
on for our timeframe.
Now, when you open the charts,
let's say you open your USD, okay?
You don't wanna go back.
What do you see at the current price, right?
What are you seeing?
Are you seeing price going up,
creating higher highs, higher lows, higher highs?
If you see like three higher highs like that,
the trend is bullish, okay?
And if you see like a market structure shift
and then a break of structure like that,
then that could be your shift in the market structure
or a reversal, okay?
Perfectly I would like to see another break of structure
like that.
So three break of like one break of structure
and two break of structures like that.
And that would be my trend reversal, specifically for this strategy.
So now that you know that, let's say that the auto flow is bullish.
Okay. So in real markets, this is not going to look like this.
It's not going to be that clean.
It's going to look something like, you know, something like that.
And then you're going to have this and then you're going to have something like that.
Yeah. So you're going to be making,
going to see price making hard highs, hard lows, hard highs like that. Cool. So now my point
here is the second point here is you have to mark out every single autoblog. So remember
the autoblog video that I thought like before like autoblog 2.0, right? You want to mark
out every single autoblog. But when you are, remember this thing, okay? For this strategy,
when you are looking at the higher time frame,
so we are currently looking at the higher time frame, right?
So let's say that this down move
is consecutive bearish candles.
So one, two, three bearish candles, okay?
When you're looking at the higher time frame,
which is the four hour, you wanna refine it, okay?
So let's say there are three candles in this leg here.
You wanna mark out the body of the last candle here, okay?
So in the auto-lock 2.0,
remember we use the body of the candle.
So you have three bearish candles, one, two, three.
That is a whole audible.
But we will define it.
We are going to refine it.
Okay.
We refine it and this is the candle.
So not what we are gonna wait for
is price to come back into our auto block.
Once that happens, we drop down to 15 minute time from.
Okay.
So you mark out, oops, mark out,
OB, near price action.
Okay.
Wait for price to come back into your OB.
Look for market structure shift during kill zone R's and entry during kill zone R's as well.
So you wait for price to come back into your auto block.
So once that happens, you drop down to 15 minutes timeframe.
You look for markers such as shift during
Kills on ours now when you're at 15 minute timeframe
So we are only using like two time frames for the strategy for our and 15 minutes
We're not gonna use any other time frame, okay?
For our and 15 minutes so now that you have a marker such a shift on 15 minute timeframe
Now you have to use the consecutive bearish candles as your autoblock and
Remember this one thing a lot of people don't get this right
So if you have something like this price did not take out the low here and then you have let's say a
Maybe a break of structure here. There was some structure here in price broke it. That is a low probability setup
I want my auto block to take out some sort of liquidity
So these are the consecutive bearish candles, right?
It if it takes out some form of liquidity could be just be a
Like a little low here right it takes out and then you have a marker structure shift now that guys
That is a hyper-wilty autoblog and let's say that there is a bigger block here as well
right so you know the definition of a bigger blocks right the first candle of this here and
the first candle and the first candle is like the of this leg right so this leg right here
the first count of this leg and the first candle of the autoblog are
In alignment with each other the size is the same here, okay?
so
You mark out this level right here right this is consecutive bearish candles on 15 minutes
Okay, you take your entry
Right there and you target one to two
You go for one to two for this trading strategy guys, okay, and you got you're gonna have above
58 to 60% wind rate with this strategy. Okay. I'm not gonna say you're gonna have like a 70%
Personality person wind rate
You're gonna have 50-60% win rate.
You are gonna easily pass your FTMO challenges
or problem challenges if you follow the strategy correctly.
Remember, this works with every single pair.
I do not try this with indices.
I will comment, you do not try this with indices.
You can back test it, but the thing is try with Forex.
Every single pair here except these ones.
Just use these main ones.
So here's the risk management for this strategy.
So once the price hits one to one risk to reward,
let's say price hits one to one risk to reward.
You move your stop loss to break even.
And then you keep the trade open till one to two is hit.
That way it is like the least,
anxiety, like I would say it's the anxiety-free
hitting strategy guys.
It's quite rule-based and one more thing.
So let's do this.
Okay, boom, boom, boom.
So let's say the trend is bullish, right?
This strategy does not require break of structure
for the auto block to be valid, okay?
So it does not have to break the high over here, right?
And then you would consider this as your POI or auto block.
No, if you know that the trend is bullish,
you mark out every single bearish candle
below the price action. So let's say that this is a bearish candle, right?
And the bullish candle closes above it. So this is the bearish candle and this is the bullish candle,
right? Even that is a valid auto block. So you wait for price to come back into this auto block.
You drop down to 15 minute timeframe. You look for market structure shift. It's going to happen
something like that. You take your entry and boom. So let's say there was like, let's do this,
something like that. Okay. This is a bearish candle, right? And after that you have a bullish candle
and the body of the bullish candle closes above the body of the bearish candle. Wicks don't matter.
So if the body closes above the bearish candle, right, bearish candles body, then that is a valid
demand zone or an auto block price comes back as long as this
as long as the low the wick is not violated. So let's say there's the wick of this auto block, right?
So you keep looking for market structure shift until this level is broken or this level is violated.
Once that happens, that auto block becomes invalid.
However, let's say that you have an auto block here.
Okay? Maybe you have an auto block here.
So you choose the body of the candle.
Oops, my bad.
You choose the body of the candle like that.
Cool.
And then you look for markers, structure shift.
On the smaller timeframe.
And you take your entry.
Couple one to two.
Simple as that.
I'll give you guys a couple of examples.
And then I'll end the video.